yeah that's right i am on set of season
eight of the mass singer season eight
that's how many kids i got
for now
yes we caught that for now nine days
after our interview nick announced he
has another baby on the way his third
with brittany bell but maybe his mass
singer judges already knew before every
show i always go to the chess room and
say hey man just
say congratulations you know season
eight baby eight and then security kicks
me out and it's a whole ritual that we
have and that's putting on a good show
so every time he goes to his dressing
room he's actually congratulating him on
the new baby yeah what's it been like
adjusting to baby number eight for you
how has it been mentally sleepless
nights yeah uh you know just trying to
do the dad thing soothing mom making
sure you know every cuz we can't do
nothing at that stage we don't have milk
you know mama yeah and then like there's
some pheromones or something there's a
connection of like mom instantly makes
them sleep and comfortable all i could
do is try to assist in help yesterday
nick posted this pic which had people
wondering if this is a new woman in
nick's life turns out she's his ex
jessica white she miscarried his baby in
2020 then broke things off after
brittany bell announced she was pregnant
with nick's baby number four shortly
after but looks like nick and jessica
have reconciled been around this block a
few times so i know i just know how not
to get yelled at just a shout out good
luck can't wait for the next one next
week
yeah this crew is tight in fact this
season they'll celebrate their 100th
episode you know over 100 episodes it's
been isn't that crazy so magically
surreal and it's it really is the gift
that keeps on giving i know it sounds
silly but it feels like yesterday when
we first like kind of met each other it
was our first show and it was like an
instant chemistry yeah yeah
we never overlap
we never interrupt let me let me let me
finish how is it going to get bigger
well it rhymes with great okay so you
know that's good eight is great we
leveled up this season i'm telling you
it's true instead of one celebrity that
gets unmasked
two each episode you get two celebrities
it's like you know it's pretty exciting
yeah i mean for us because we realize
that we love the performances but the
unmasking is kind of the you know which
you get all excited when you find out
who it really is and if your guesses
were correct it could be mr knight
writer himself oh no david no castle
there you
they got this battle royale uh concept
where you have to literally sing the
same song and whoever sings it better is
the one that champions at night some of
the guest judges include leslie jordan
tori spelling and joel mchale but
remember those headlines speculating tom
brady is one of the mass singers after
he missed 11 days of the preseason with
no explanation will tom shot down the
rumors upon his return i'm 45 years old
man there's a lot going on so
it truly is my favorite season there's
so many surprises yeah and see i think
it's my favorite season season eight
premieres september 21st on fox
meanwhile we'll be seeing nick's lady
bree t-a-z on season six of selling
sunset gonna pop up you're gonna buy
some real estate where i mean hey i'm
always looking you never i mean it's uh
congratulations to her because i mean
obviously even before you know the world
knew that we were involved and had a
child together she has been a dynamite
in the space of real estate so for her
to go on there and do her thing i mean
she's always selling
60 100 million properties and stuff like
that so for people to get to see the
side of her i'm excited for
[Music]
you